the trial of a former los angeles angels
employee accused of supplying drugs that
killed angel's pitcher tyler skaggs is
revealing how the nation's opioid
epidemic has reached major league
baseball omar villafranca is in fort
worth texas where closing arguments in
the trial of eric k are expected to
begin today omar good morning
good morning the defense arrested
yesterday without former angels
communication director eric k taking the
stand listen baseball is america's past
time and some people even argue it's a
reflection of american society what this
trial exposed is a continued problem in
the sport with current and former
players talking about drug use and abuse
during the season
and down goes to lez third strike out of
the night for tyler skaggs los angeles
angels pitcher tyler skaggs was found
dead on july 1st 2019 in a dallas fort
worth area hotel room ahead of a series
between the angels and the texas rangers
a coroner's report found skaggs had a
toxic mix of alcohol fentanyl and
oxycodone in his system the prosecution
alleges before he died skaggs received
counterfeit oxycodone containing
fentanyl from eric k a former angels
public relations official
and for more than a week of trial
federal prosecutors have argued that
only k could have supplied the drugs
that killed skaggs but kaye's attorneys
argue that while kaye was giving skaggs
opioids it's not clear who gave skaggs
the lethal dose and testimony from
former players and friends indicated
that skaggs had other suppliers among
them former all-star pitcher and
teammate matt harvey who admitted under
subpoena and with immunity to helping
skaggs get oxycodone during the season
harvey also testified that he himself
had taken drugs supplied by kay they
need a preponderance of evidence for
not beyond a reasonable doubt but the
most likely situation that eric gave him
those drugs
in texas
sam blum covers the angels for the
athletic he says the testimony from some
players that they also acquired and
abused opioids and other drugs
highlights drug use among major league
players
are you surprised
at some of the things you're hearing in
court about the drug use from players
i mean listen i all across america
people are dealing with this
epidemic of opioids this industry is
particularly susceptible to some issue
like this because
players are actually diagnosed and given
oxy real oxycodone medication
to recover from surgeries to then what
ends up happening which is an addiction
to these pills
blum also pointed out that most major
league baseball players are not
superstars and their livelihood and
their paycheck really depend on being
physically available for more than 160
games a year it's also worth noting that
since skaggs died major league baseball
started testing players for opioids and
they're not offering punishment they're
offering treatment for players who test
positive michelle
treatment that is an option omar thank
you so much